I came to the realization that Diablo
Cody is like a mirror image of me minus
her stripper Saga and the divorces for
one she's a huge horror movie fan after
she won the Oscar for her first script
Juno she basically had free reign to do
whatever she wanted and she didn't
hesitate to choose horror my entire life
had dreamed of writing a horror movie
I'm a huge horror fan she also ghost
wrote the 2013 Evil Dead and wrote the
upcoming Lisa Frankenstein besides her
love of horror and being a writer she
also seems to be interested in emo which
is very evident in the movie we
definitely knew we wanted a rock sound
kind of a punk sound I don't know if you
notic screeing weel is in the movie
that's one of my favorite bands and then
of course you guys and and she's
apparently a huge roller coaster
Enthusiast I'm super super super
obsessed with roller coasters I've
traveled all over I've written hundreds
of roller coasters anyone who has seen
my Final Destination 3 video or seen me
in the comment section of every roller
coaster YouTuber or just anyone who
follows me on Instagram knows that
coasters are one of my top four main
passions and on top of all that she's
from Chicago